what's up everybody it's adam ak here
for anime uproar and welcome to another
episode of rant cafe number 48 i believe
and in this episode it's going to be a
great fun time we're discussing etsy
anime and thus edgy anime suck punning
thank you by the way your after dis rank
afraid we're going to have an
after-party in our discord server link
in the description voice chat after
party we're gonna be kind of hanging out
talking about all the ways we triggered
recon so if you want to join us on this
cord feel free to do that joining me
today we have a full house of awesome
guests including for the first time ever
Holden Casanova formerly known as Holden
reviews a fine gentleman former cast
member of PAS talk what's up my man has
a good I'm soon pretty well I'm really
excited about is you know a lot about it
yeah same year pleasure to meet you and
your cat of course thank you we also
have back again Nala gotta this time
showing her face and her awesome fooly
cooly poster yes sorry I'm trying to get
white closer into so I'm like in the
middle but I have a desk right here
hello everyone I grab me again
little girl confirmed yeah you know
perfect for don't know yet I guess I
guess you never do no soul maka is here
with us yep
good to see you sold also of course we
have anime recon we could not do this
episode without him he could not yeah
boys
what homicide has come the edgy Harun
King has arisin has arisen and finally
joining me us as well is NOx Taku and by
the way we just recently he uploaded on
his channel eight challenge where he
challenged me to guess terrible anime
descriptions I've left the link to that
as well in the description as well as
the link to everybody's channels
here so be sure to check that out that
was a fun time not just a fun
frustrating time but thank you yes for
having me and welcome thank you so much
always good to be here and I expect a
rematch when you have the balls to write
enough good descriptions for me okay
it's gonna happen all right
I'm looking forward first me too me too
I saw them I feel like I'm very nice
very good also by the way the bonus Suba
video who is the best girl in college
super videos dropping tomorrow knocks I
think you will like it I did manage in
you in that one as well because I have
to but yeah I think you will enjoy that
and now let's get into the next guys
first can we confirm is there going to
be a new season of high school yes there
is so lose we saw the new preview for DX
new season four and they changed a lot
of claims in it yes but then I did not
see any any official news it was kind of
most like a trailer it looks like it's
animated by pink pineapple now so maybe
oh yeah more than we expected before
season 1 2 & 3
there's juicy staff there they should
have [ __ ] done though why do they
give it to a hentai company but they
didn't it's not actually pink pineapple
it just has a designer who worked 15
pineapple years ago I think it's a huge
improvement overall there it's a lot
more it's a lot less rigid so it should
be easier to animate so yes you are
making here in terms of is what is the
point of edge and let's let's talk about
how we define edgy in the first place
the way I define edgy is stuff that is
not that is are we getting background
noise someone what's happening
okay now I gotta have to uh strangle
some people in her home okay okay
Ohio everybody Jay Paul is from there
what can you do but yes so my questions
you know people are saying how do you
define Etsy because there's a lot of
animate with FG components for fan
service and the way I want to define
edgy is something like highschool DxD
that has such a heavy focus on edge that
it distracts you because like yeah anime
like guru McGann Code Geass they have
that she for sure but the plot is still
central to me an anime like High School
DxD than Cairo which I've loved and so
on like these types of anime are the
focus really is edgy let's face it and
so is there really a point to having
ecchi anime white why not either watch
anime or go full hentai that's my
question to all of you I'm gonna
disagree with you on how you define
itchy because you're already casting it
in the light that it can't be good cuz
it's just you know not an anime with the
plot it's only focused on you know over
sexualizing women yeah that's a fair
point that's a fair point I disagree
exactly it's a genre like every other
genre you know there's action anime but
the action anime can also have a plot
and can also be edgy it just means that
there are over sexualized women and over
bouncing boobs everywhere I don't
understand this content concept of over
sexualized
are you saying there can be enough
sexualized normal I'm not saying more
than necessary okay I understand by the
way someone in the chat let me see who
it was that the I was 8 8 Tasker or
whatever says Eddie is why Japan has low
birth rates in socio-economic as well I
mean yeah it's definitely like it's a
cancer in itself but it's also a
blessing and itself to you because
there's examples where a chi was
presented
and either funny comical ways that made
something like a series more comical or
it kind of had a sexy tone you know what
I mean I mean think of High School of
the Dead I mean think of how you know if
you - the ecchi from it it was a
straight-up horror you know what I mean
but the fact that they threw that and
there it kind of added that a little bit
of comical edge to it you know what I
mean there's there's cases where it can
be done really classy full of the dead I
found it more immersion breaking than
comp comedic Wow
when I was watching my 2d cartoons I was
really worried about my immersion yeah
that's how you do it it's how you put
the etching how you involve it in the
anime you know what I mean it can either
come off as comical it'll come off sexy
or it'll come off as cancer overplay so
depending how you do it I think that
there at its core is the distinction
between a sheet and end time is usually
the distinction of like for instance
edgy is aimed to simulate a phenomena
known as blue balls which is getting
someone to the point of ejaculation
without allowing them to do so creating
a prolonged sense of orgasm or a high
stimulation so when you something like
why do you have to pick on stuff that's
like that's why it's important to be
specific because the line between Eddie
and hentai if you - a very inexperienced
you are sometimes seen which anime is
blurred I would say it's almost
invisible because how could you look at
something like any of those fanservice
shows and maybe how they can go against
your definition of what you think anti
is it's all about because it's very
there it's all based on the wording
because it's you know the only thing
that doesn't occur is like you know
probably penetration or entry of any
kind anymore
there's an anime this season with
penetration yeah I mean I'm not saying
that I'm not saying that those define it
entirely and that's why I didn't say
that was the case if you could say
something even that does it in a
progressive way so if you take something
like
even with the was it's two seasons again
there it was about the OS comes with she
has the English title where it uses sex
it uses sex to facilitate a point and
not as a focal point for like mindless
titillation its seduced in a very
different way different ducts one sec
this is a good point because the whole
blue balling aspect is what personally I
don't see the appeal of in most at sheet
anime now again I guess the amount of a
cheaper anime is what we define it that
if you don't agree with me in terms of
actually being the focus but like for
example High School of the Dead there's
so much edgy there's so much focused on
it that you know it's an edgy anime
however it is also for enemies so it's
an interesting it's a nuanced thing my
brother essay on it it's interesting Kay
Joyce well it is a focus focuses on the
edgy there's a lot of edgy in it whereas
Code Geass has that G in it but I
wouldn't call it an edgy anime
say absolutely yes fan art there is a
lot of it but the whole thing that I'm
trying to say is what is the point of
let's say you're watching a heavily
ecchi anime even though like for example
K Joe the humor I loved it doesn't take
itself seriously I love that well you
know what is the point of watching on
Etsy anime that maybe isn't doesn't have
as much humor or plot rather than just
watching a hentai that does that also
doesn't have much plot but at least it
gets you all the way like you know what
I mean what is what if hey hey Joe is
more of a sports comedy than it is an
edgy because I think edgy is focusing
more on the sexual you know aspects just
like I'd say shokugeki no souma is more
of a shounen than it is an edgy it
doesn't have to show off the sexual
aspects Tom Knox to focus more so on
edgy what you mean like highschool DxD
well yeah technically yeah so highschool
DxD is edgy but it also has plot in
there yeah but what are the stories
overwhelming Thank You Holden
what's overwhelming though the edgy or
the plot huh I think both good honest I
wouldn't mind having both high school it
is super I don't know it's a super hard
case to talk about I'm super fond of it
it's I'm super fond of it I love it for
it's actually because of its story
favorite I read the manga back in 2012
when it was airing the untimely demise
of Daisuke Sato means of course will
that we'll see a finish to it or that's
not an official one due to him passing
away but it was something that I was
super invested in and I feel like the
anime really stopped at the point where
it could really prove itself there's an
arc immediately following the anime
where they go into a mall and it's very
inspired by something like Dave the dead
and it's such a cool take of just the
survival genre and everything and it
really elevates itself because it really
is pretty wacky people are paying on
each other
bully like boobs they're dodging bullets
it's really absurd up into that point
because I feel like even though manga
cuz we're at this time the writers
really hadn't found their own style
because it would cover it's about three
volumes which if you think about it's
probably just one year because it was a
monthly series at the time so twelve
chapters and it makes sense but it's a
really shame that we're not gonna see
more of it of course it's madhouse we
wouldn't see more of it anyway as you
know Matt house is pretty notorious for
not even doing anything even we think
they are like with one punch man season
two somehow they handed off the spoils
of thinking no one will notice
yeah we even had a whole episode
actually talking about what the hell is
happening with one punch man season two
which has been confirmed
since the over a year ago and now we're
thinking okay so we're gonna get the
release date Oh actually we're switching
Studios and switching the director oh my
god is this even gonna happen but yeah
good point no huge shame it's like they
don't like second seasons that's for
sure
you know you can't wait a movie they
didn't make a movie of no game their
life as well as a regular high school
movie right that is a movie the guy
looks like Kenji is but then again I
mean overlords getting a second season
yeah it's jihad review you also got a
second season right we're diverting a
lot I think that matter specifically is
a really odd case with Chico's of course
we're not a company they're not a studio
we've been associated with like who do
you think that we would normally
associate at you with because my pumps
of mine is you know Xebec j.c.staff was
a to me do they come to mind for me I'm
with you guys I'd love to hear your
opinion on which studios you feel like
have just a a name or a knack for making
at you as far as a name or a knack I
would say if it's an action ecchi or an
action fantasy edgy half the time it's a
one picture yeah absolutely
totally yes so personally I would
differentiate between something like no
game no life which has heavy elements
but you know it's not just a chi sir and
you know kill a kill which i think it
does edgy right and but is not just
actually there's a you know the plot is
the focus whereas for example no game no
life i think they're edgy is not done
well because it's just pandering to fans
it's just tropes pandering tropes
whereas with kilakila it's actually done
creatively and in an interesting way but
would be like don't forget about you
know to Levu greatest edges of all time
actually it's a just last week turned 10
years old to love who did and it had a
special event which had the likes of
even accurate Orianna showed up and did
art for it as yeah Araki that are the
artists of JoJo's everyone came to show
their support for Tolliver the
longest-running Shonen in the jump in
the past 10 years so that was a really
cool moment if you guys got a chance to
a special issue or it it's really worth
it a lot of really cool artists in it I
need to see some Jojo edgy though it was
it was amazing seeing akira toriyama cuz
he hadn't made an appearance in jump in
since San Lang and in 2007 so it was
really cool is of all things resurrected
he's a very very like super selective
he's got you know Dragon Ball Z pretty
big on intellectual property right there
he's got Dragon Quest I don't think the
man ever needs to wear chicken he can
just do character designs his whole life
if you want Steven it's like inventing
like Pokemon or dragon ball or something
you do that you're done you don't need
any more money you don't need anything
yeah so I'm not a big watch or ecchi per
se because of the whole blue balling
concept you know I'll watch anime with
fanservice
I'll watch that other thing but the
middle thing called that chief I don't
watch much of like I said I appreciate
it
I salute the dead I appreciated Keijo
for the humor and and all that and kind
of the commentary the satire aspect but
I'm not a big fan of it G so that's why
I'm trying to see you know what is the
appeal of just your generic edgy that
just basically blue balls you but
doesn't really you know isn't noteworthy
in terms of being a great comedic piece
or anything like that
and remember this is what you need to
convince me that these edgy series are
worth my time such as hajimeta no gala
which I dropped after like two episodes
I don't blame you man I mean after that
fat guy who just kept blamed the fat guy
mapping out the little kids and you know
little kids is the reason why an actor
to start it oh our or right now what's
going on with the little little sister
is all you need
holy crap and also that show [ __ ]
animate where there's literally it's
literally the humor is horrible there's
literally a seen this little girl cares
something and says oh now at or so the
mother says don't worry it'll hurt no
more when you carry your hymen looks
have you seen the latest episode of show
[ __ ] you think you watch it you have to
watch the latest every coloring is
criticism
you're just saying you have to watch the
last episode recon i watch okay
so just cuz I knew I was coming here
today by the way I watched all three
and the humor is the same the whole way
through it's just oh let's say a word
that sounds sexual it's hilarious that's
the comedy yeah
man knocks we're both completely
different people we have both we have
different tastes on how we take things
so I found it funny I don't know about
you knocks you probably didn't find it
funny because you're on achievement guy
I'm an ex you guys so yeah called
hajimeta no girl fat guy just look him
up your take on edgy anime my take on
ecchi anime well first of all I don't
know I like I I understand and include
animate that have like say hg element in
it not like just full-blown and she
focused but if you want to talk about
like specifically the edgy focus ones
like you know to love ruin and stuff
like that then I would say they can be
enjoyable like how you found
Keijo enjoyable because there's like a
comedy element to it like for me I love
to love that was that's hilarious it was
funny it was really funny because it was
like he liked the guy couldn't help but
like stumble or drop or do some that we
just turn into some kind of a tree
moment and there was loads of like great
characters in the cars even though like
they're just there for like the whole
edgy aspect but you know the characters
themselves were enjoyable like I think
Yui who was the class president kind of
girl or disciplinary committee thing
like she was my favorite from that
there's oh good yeah so I'm just told me
about rosario vampire but yeah well I
see that one that one really annoyed me
but hold on hold on back to to love room
for one second you know the name girl I
think her name is Momo but I'm not good
with
names uh veggies which was in the second
season yeah mom was the ones that
basically is the one with the pink hair
he's like the main girl but don't worry
we saw her enough that we could focus on
many other pairs of tits that we don't
need to worry about her anymore yeah
yeah so that's like yeah you got it
we're all rise it's just not the same as
sa yo I don't know what we're saying
like the lack of inclusion from Lala is
the same as the lack of inclusion for
Massino no there was some good no there
was inclusion of the second and the
third season but for the rest of the
girls and they say yo there wasn't much
when button - LaRue was completely
different so I don't know why it would
be the same as si yo well I haven't I
haven't seen the tool of who thing you
reviewed on both but I'm just I'm just
I'm just trying to trigger you which is
what I was doing here
now I know you figure me and I'm trying
to fix this [ __ ] because I'm the actual
Aaron King again Holden if you think
he's being ironic he's not he really you
really want the arm king and he loves
this [ __ ] and we love him and it's a
great time the reason I asked Seoul
specifically is because he's a hentai
artist so I'm interested in what he
actually thinks about these edgy anime
that are not quite hentai but you know
ya know what do you mean like how do I
feel about the whole blueballs aspect
what's the playing guy like halfway when
you could just go all the way yeah I
mean like
I think that is only for kids to be
honest because it's the young young
audience of young minded people that
will more see it for that
whereas I will look at to love room not
for the tits in US but for the comedy
that's what I'm watching it
oh yeah oh comedy hurry to words coming
out of your mouth like wow this is a
respectable you know no no but that's
all saying that's what for it's like if
I'm watching
Keijo I'll be watching that for the
comedy yeah may I want to see all these
BOTS come out of the sky
like freakin Gilgamesh any kind of you
know excitement that's just gonna be
funny
did they've done a pun right you know I
mean so it could be for something it can
do both okay yeah but it has to be both
it can't just be you know to turn you on
agree which is what what I think is the
point why I don't like most HG anime but
I do like ones that are strong with
comedy like Cage oh and by the way feel
free to recommend me some good actually
anime like Cage or that I might actually
enjoy without just feeling cheated my
iMac 27 watch that no please watch
almost like a really weird one would you
as fast fighters Oh Mikey no soma or
food wars it's the JoJo's of cooking
just with ng no no no it's not man no
there's there's no real plot to to
shokugeki no souma
until just recently in the manga where
there's this central thing that is
coming to it okay well if you're coming
to it before things just it's just
generic like ramen perspective my hero
academia doesn't have that much plot
either at this point in the anime either
ah
well turn to minority
yeah well there was a although all the
low balls that were thrown at the
characters in my hero academia were okay
the villains attacked the school the
teacher saved whatever that's nice but
that's equivalent to a much you know
smaller perspective as well there's this
guy isin in food wars not to be confused
with the bleach you know loser but
business right so he wanted to or
essentially trying to kick soma out of
school would be an equivalent to Deku I
don't know losing his power or whatever
but the major difference though is that
my hero academia doesn't have a
secondary genre food where's does yeah
yeah but the edgy in food wars is as a
supplement to comedy because sex sells
and that's the only way that they're
gonna push out a food anime they the
whole goal is they cook food for someone
to eat it when someone eats it what
happens blow their load that's that's
the whole point of it so the whole focus
is what them eating the food and
reaction they get and who gets where
someone being a better cook is
equivalent to someone being a better
hero in my hero academia or all better
lover here's a good thing to ask a good
anime that's a that's a good question to
ask yourself if there's an edgy anime
that you're watching if I take all of
the sexual nasaw love the edginess out
of it anime is it still a good anime no
okay yo people's reaction the people's
reaction do matter if they exploded and
closing them up and we see their boobs
yes that is lazy wow there's a lot more
comedic acting too
we need that [ __ ] bro that's when you
know an anime [ __ ] yes indeed and she
unable to survive unable to have a good
storyline unable to make comedic jokes
you guys don't understand and recon is
defending edgy from a perspective that
he loves it not because he's saying oh
I'm not sexy edgy well one one anime
that I thought of that when you were
talking now I was cocky GUI that anime
without the weird rape faces and you
know and the whole fanservice stuff like
there would be nothing unique about the
concept of cocky GUI and I don't think
he was nearly as popular if it didn't
have such weird-ass edgy hold it
absolutely the over you know I don't
know I don't know cuz I mean I don't
know you can really call a weed rape
face edgy
that's that's like I don't know I don't
think I think is really good I think
kakigori was I think a lot of people are
giving it are upset about it but I
understand why for sure it's made by
mapa so they're delivering really high
product like a really high level product
of course the previous SG anime the only
one of which they've made so far if
you're excluding Yuri on ice is going to
be something more like punch line which
is a really good example of like what I
think that you guys would enjoy it's
such a punch these crazy lunch lady is a
crazy edgy it is really cool it's super
unique yo we'll have a cat watching porn
in one scene and then you'll have a girl
[ __ ] slapping robbers with me straw in
the next scene yeah yeah
that's an over not the kind of [ __ ] you
like knocks cuz you're such a fan of
JoJo's Jojo just has two good arcs out
of three volumes as I think maybe around
42 finds I remember the pod cop who
Holden and Gygax Bizarre Adventure SPR
is the only one worth really
experiencing the rest is kind of still
like he got fighting
you tooth-and-nail on this pointing yeah
I remember him you know but as I was
gonna say before she is when when they
end up changing like the kind of
material that we know so like Rosario
vampire that series turned to a pure
like home
edgy unnecessarily so when like manga is
nothing like that at all
same like freezing that and so when
really and truly one it's a lot more
deeper than that and yeah when those
kind of things happen yeah it's the
whole you know sex cells mentality but I
think it just ends up ruining the show
of course some people will like that
because they like edgy in that right
recon oh boy you know for me it's just
like yeah it just ruins it for me
because I know how good the story could
have been but you wound it so I don't
and all have a aversion to actually
because of some moral you know
sexualizing thing I have no problem with
it I think well what I mean I have no
problem if you want something we're
object hold on we go if anything we're
objectifying fictional woman's which is
better than actual porn come on guys
anyways the thing is that I'm like I I
don't mind that aspect at all but I
don't like the I just get bored quickly
with anime that are strictly actually
not a good plot and it's just kind of
it's just kind of tease you or you know
do you have these and these tropes and
fan pandering what that just kind of
like goes on and on so the kind of itchy
that I appreciate are like hey Joe that
is really funny that kind of gets you
are it's hilarious like they know what
they're doing they don't take themselves
too seriously and that's the aspect I
enjoy of it so like I said I'm not
against at she per se I'm just saying
that it's very rare for me to find one
that I enjoy so hold them any that you
would recommend sir yes muscle muscle
pre-con watch muscle got good HHO
literally you must make these girls get
turned on give them power boosts that's
the plot yes that's the best plot not be
a head type that is the perfect plot for
hentai Seco no quays earn it yes the
baby's good leave you've already seen if
you've already seen prison school I'd
say the next best thing would be
something like oh boy at the same time
everybody I'm gonna I'm gonna start
muting people if you guys keep talking
the same well then so you said Prison
school Golden Boy Gaja two
recommendations solid that's
specifically cater to you though judging
by what you said that you look for an
edgy I'd say so I think the other thing
that you have to realize is that the
reason that actually gets away with
doing comedy I guess some quotation
marks is because it's since it's
guaranteed to sell the joke doesn't have
to hit um that's the reason it's a
supplement where even if the joke
doesn't necessarily resonate with the
audience you can still make it whereas
if you have a pure comedy series if that
joke doesn't hit immediately it doesn't
work if you think I'm just how many pure
comedy series there are there's very few
and in the past decade there's even less
than ever the last songs that I can
think of are stuff like you know the one
with the oats AMA the one with all the
the guys who have the same there's
different colors from 1979 yeah yeah
with the Matsu brothers I think that's
that revivals did purely comedy anime
but I mean those are very rare because
again nichijou I would say that like
birth so saying Ishii Joe was 10 years
ago
punch man has a lot of comedy yeah yeah
that battle Shonen though only like it
sounds like he really enjoys a comedy
and finding a pure comedy anime is going
to be nigh impossible
in today's like landscape for anime how
do you define kono Suba comedy
they just set up a setting so that the
jokes can hit harder no he's right like
a boy like a flat-out weird the only
genre you can actually put that anime in
is just comedy has happened in years I
mean like it's already high school
promoting ideal for me but the last one
that really was just fuel comedy because
it takes place every day and it's like
last year tanaka kun is always listless
yes i that was the pure comedy and was
hilarious
psyche gusto no sign on why are you
getting so worked up man should chill i
mean it's just like at my point is is
that either few and far between and i
think that you're further making my
point exemplified by only listing i
don't know 3 so far but they're all from
last year
Wow so out of 53 out of the 185 anime
that came out last year we've got three
almost a percent Wow well how many good
anime came out last year how many would
you say are good I don't know I don't
watch much animes farce last year I've
only watched like maybe 20 or so dim
pretty good I would say ah ho girl is
good Auto girl is super funny ain't not
right it's all subjective the whole girl
is fantastic and that's why my
suggestion to him is this because I mean
it's really rare just it sounds like
what do you enjoyed in K Joe was just
how absurd it was and that's rare to
find I think by saying it's commonplace
was a disservice to anime isn't medium
miss a whole because it's not the case
at all you'd be like through your own
teeth it's commonplace I'm just saying
that there are pure comedies that exist
that are funny
I would agree Holden I would agree with
your point because kono Suba is a
hilarious anime but it is specifically a
SAP
tire of the Shi Zhang right so it's not
just like something that I take a look
at just comedy would be like daily lives
of high-school boys like that to me
would be just a comedy but it is rare to
find a comedy that is good that isn't
action as well or fantasy as well or
most of them are gonna be end up being
romance as well like if you if you take
away the slice of life romance from the
comedy you get very few straight-up con
kanaka kun has none of that it's purely
just comedy fantastic watch that one yes
shamone oh yeah that's a G and comedy as
well both we're not looking yeah we were
talking about just kind of that's what I
know we're talking about comedy which is
why I suggested C Mon arrow which is
also comedy and edgy is well we're just
trying to say that it's very rare it's
just weird because they're mixing genres
and just to sell it even more you know
on its own like think about like all of
the automobile things and all the
motorcycle things up coming out what I
hear all of them always combined with
cute girls or something right it's it's
done it's a marketing ploy because they
have to sell it a certain way because if
we don't sell it for a we have to sell
it for B that's why it's really rare
that pure edgy kind of exists because a
lot of it is just an element to
guarantee sales or at least try to
insure them well for usually another
submersed theme so in some cases it's
sports in other cases it's comedy it's
usually edgy and it's always really
rarely different like found on its own
and she's almost always paired with some
sort of comedy if there's no comedic
value in the edgy for me it gets really
old but it's still sell cuz I mean you
can say there's at chena code geass but
it's not what comedy is you get
overcomes us yeah but I don't like the
edgy of code geass
I would do fine without it I would
prefer without it Wow get on it
I don't mind Aichi being part fanservice
being part of an anime but I don't want
it to be just in my face at a point that
it's insulting and contrived like no
game no life like no game of life it's
so contrived it's so cliche it's so on
your face that you're just like man I
feel insulted by this actually like if
you got make actually make it plausible
make it plausible situations I don't
make it so cliche so predictable and
then I'm totally cool with it it's not
the edgy that's the problem it's how you
introduce it you actually put an effort
and making it an experience or are you
just like here's some moves by this or
here's some boobs like this associate
dis with boobs so you can you like this
and buy the product which I think Holden
has a great point a lot of stuff is just
marketed through ecchi but I mean that's
human nature you see as youtubers we
know that something else with boobs like
the only way that it can really sell and
blast out even to younger audiences so
that's really really sad is that it's
like that's just it's really really
annoying in a sense it is kind of
cancerous you know what I mean it kind
of is it's just kind of those a little
bit as far as one second going on that
primal instinct right it's like what
boobs didn't click which is why I
appreciate your shirt Holden more mature
than that you know what I mean you were
supposed to be like you don't know what
you mean sorry because it's it's it's
all goes on instinct on the internet
like clickbait and all that stuff it all
goes on instinct this video just put it
uses pads for anything it doesn't have
to be just sex it's gonna be something
like like a fake scandal
Brad Pitt murdered three clowns like you
know thought oh [ __ ] this sounds
interesting Brad Pitt murdered clowns
like what not click on this ad if you
are under 18 or have heart problems for
sure my doctors don't want you to know
this yeah yeah doctors hate him because
he but as far as no game no life goes
there were two parts to the ecchi there
were the mindless okay what are we gonna
do for the next five minutes well let's
just put them all in a bath together
there was that scene and then there were
the ones that were actually really funny
like where Steph was trying to I don't
know win bets against him or whatever
and he didn't care he knew he'd beat
beat her and all of them anyway
so he would just say okay so you have to
remove an article of clothing every time
you lose and that was comedic how the
progression went and she kept trying
back had to do with the dynamics of the
world and was funny yeah but look at the
they were just the shower scenes were
horrible and also also the emote abate
was so [ __ ] stupid oh dude dude
anyways now we're demonetized how about
my I don't expect my wife well I'm
pretty sure I know why the challenge
video with you guys be monetized it's
way did it get the monetize dynamic did
it
everything it's a month it's like every
Red Cafe get the monetize for some
reason now that this video will
definitely get DiMaggio talking Google's
doing it goodwill is like you know what
I'm gonna get you my Google Hangouts my
wife is the student council president
best hgl I don't know I wouldn't be
surprised I think Google might give us
ads on this one cuz like whoa someone
used Google Hangouts yes ma'am
we use Google Hangouts for anchor faith
because it's the easiest way not to have
to do editing or anything of any sort
sure
so much tag not sponsored yeah we're you
know man if Google sponsored me I'd be
I'll have like a headband that says cool
just like a Naruto oh yeah so for Anchor
Bay what we do is we just record we
don't even prepare we just come here and
just like rant with people we call it
okay so we can have that kind of as a
backing like oh yeah it's not serious
yeah so unlike pod talk who which like
took months for an episode to be put
together and [ __ ]
Ross it's just like it's just like let's
let's just see what happens let's all
just go in here see what happens
talk about empty recon versus knocks if
we are society people have been asking
that to happen recon one is it happen
one thing I have to say Holden one of
the reasons that made me really want to
invite you specifically for this rant
cafe was because you mentioned in a pod
Taku if I remember correctly that you
would always try to watch Iquitos in' in
planes to attract attention yeah Akito
son was alright the first two seasons we
got was so um why do you guys think
about other people noticing your
addiction to edgy mostly targeted at
recon yeah I guess maybe I don't know it
depends anime something you watch at
home yeah well that's the thing anime is
become more and more mainstream there's
a lot of misconceptions about it for
sure and I just actually got my first
ever anime body pillow guys let me see
it I can't reveal in the next video
that's dropping tomorrow who is the true
best girl in Kona Suba when did you get
it Anna Mack real
it's literally darkness and that is
actual fanservice
yeah I'm gonna show my it my pillow it's
gonna reveal so is the true best girl in
my opinion so I don't can't show it 21
and better be ramnik I love the cue
cards
just like to put us back on track
because often we go off track and then
just like oh pie we got it we're on
track that's gonna be revealed tomorrow
my first ever body pill but I totaled
out because when Knox asked that
question it's like it is a bit weird to
have a body pillow in your anywhere in
your house because it's a big thing it's
hard to hide it and if someone sees it
they're like you know it's hard to
explain you know like if you're a DVD
it's one thing but if you have a whole
huge body pill it's not especially if
she's completely naked that's yeah
that's even harder easily there's two
sides to the pillow man two sides you
you can't defend that shadow Mike my
body pillow so cool no now if everybody
knows I haven't - - they put a shirt
over it and a skirt to it what no as
your body pillow - sided with one that's
it's two-sided
but I will show in the video the video
yes if she's if she saw it yeah you know
wrap it around just wrap it around so we
don't see it okay
just wrap around sound like he has
experience with us anyone else other
because I know has several body pillow
some a body pillow here yeah I only have
one body pillow which is 0.3
do I all right I found one on the beach
back when I lived in Chiba which is on
the beach yeah it was so when you live
in Japan you find show in the beach all
time and so I found a butter your body
pillow on the beach so I immediately
knew what that was used for no I'm just
gonna say rules
fling sexualisation in Japan is really
interesting that I think the reason that
there's so much actually even exists is
because sexualization in Japan is so
commonplace for instance breasts are
like never censored in regardless of any
medium the documentary be it film it's
never censored it's not considered
genitalia um which is a great difference
and so it's whereas I guess on the other
point they have a lot of weird censoring
for actual genitals is what they can
like for penises and vaginas they have a
for instance a black bar system that
they have to use or mosaic so they have
to use that I believe the actual
percentage is that there's someone's job
at a publishing studio and their job is
to measure the surface area of genitals
so that they can censor an exact amount
of the surface area using the black
lists like bars and that's why in your
Dow Jones and stuff kids you see so many
black bars it's somebody went through
found at the land mass of that genitalia
sensor to just enough within the legal
limits of the Japanese law yeah I felt I
have to do that if I just want to say
[ __ ] that guy who does that
literally best job oh yeah I have to do
that one of these pitches for anti
pitches for pixiv yes I of course it
runs by Japanese law so I have to do the
black bars and cover genitalia people
don't do black bars no they just do the
sunrays with the anime that they want
you to buy the blu-ray where they pull
down the punch then suddenly there's a
ray of light like lollies and tentacles
and stuff like that it was also a forum
around there's like so many different
types of censorship even in the bath
scenes there you're gonna see like steam
just going around the entire budget like
that
d-did they would like a chi anime the
ones that really like you know push the
boat out there yeah I wouldn't even call
it chadmarco hentai is yo suka no sora I
mean like oh my god no like when I found
out on anime site I was always confused
why it was that because I already read
the manga already knew was about I was
like why is that even there let me check
out and see if they're sensitive like I
did do with things like you know fairy
tale whatever else I watched it and they
still had the scene where he ejaculated
on his sister's face for me
incest is only cool if it's not related
by blood okay if it's your luck
they can't allocate so much resources to
making quality nice quality and large
quotation works
HD anime it's not commonplace whereas in
Maya it's a lot easier of course you
have an artist in usually their
assistants producing what they believe
is like the best for cooking abilities
and so that's why it's usually the stark
contrast is pretty pretty clean you can
usually tell an itchy anime literally by
the way to shaded or like
highlighted in the anime it's like if it
looks poor enough you're like either a
this enemies from 2007 or B it's
probably Nazi anime you can just tell
immediately am I looking at it usually
what it's trying to do all right here's
a good question what turns you on the
most popsicle sucking their ice cream
sucking sorry popsicle sucking or a
finger second which one I really I
really need to get those colors no come
on knocks answer it please please I feel
completely defeated this time ice cream
I spent an hour talking about my least
favorite part of anime oh damn well your
least favorite part about just saying
wow how is that how can you accept the
medium whenever I would say almost 30%
is some element of SEO fanservice well I
don't mind when there's some element I
mind when it's the main element I know I
think a lot of people not old-timers
would be like back in my day all we
there was people punching each other we
didn't have any of this this
heterosexual [ __ ] in the screen damn
kids anime was berserk bro even with
like Cowboy Bebop
we got some nice nice bay Valentine
fanservice of course the legend leader
designer where all the women are femme
fatales and all the men are badass
I love his designs they're so good also
even you know rows of her Styles like I
know that Rose if you know I'm saying
so no side of a key
yeah even like galaxy Express 3:9 had
some entry you know you're trying to
prove to me that every ecchi anime is
bad
I think that every anime that's only
focused on edgy without them knowing
that ridiculous is that yeah III feel
that Knox I understand you like I said
if it's straight up Eddie there's not
much humor why not just go ahead time
which is like no plot going at the point
or just yeah or just be like a key surah
or your Segundo sore does that they're
basically hentai basically you gotta
talk so did we see your screen yeah it's
so what's going on is I actually tried
touching your cowl mothers and favorite
characters in it so I got somewhat
original cells line stuff that can use
an original designer so of course you
just have eyes there oh now he's a super
good designer he's the guy also the
designer of uh Golden Boy which is where
he got all like a lot of his style was
from that more recently he's done kick
ice ensign which is why he always tries
to make women look like femme fatales
and men try to be as badass as possible
You shant character yeah yeah I mean
he's uh it's super unique I like his
style like because all the characters
look unique and that's something that
he's really big on is making a character
super recognizable yeah I love gobbler
be about the characters in that show are
just so iconic the design the characters
inspired by burning chrome by William
Gibson like I [ __ ] love that
cowboy bebop was perfect even the
English dub was done well and that's
something that you don't hear a lot of
people say no yeah but I disagree with
perfect yeah I do like Cowboy Bebop I
don't like the way it was you're wrong
get out of here no detracting and I it
was perfect me away the only thing that
wasn't no it wasn't person to soon
because I love the characters so much
and the interplay between Faye on the
jet spike and Edie
so much and I would have watched a
hundred episodes of
then just like for me the past was more
interesting than the present
they made the present then just feel
like filler it was just like random jobs
you know looking for a dog and [ __ ]
there's so much like set like that's the
whole point it's supposed to like cast
you into all these different stories and
make you think and then once in a while
they come back to the characters and
they give you like this contrast of them
that gives you a whole entire new
complex on the story moving forward well
you don't even get that it was good but
it wasn't perfect no to me it was
perfect
yeah so yeah I would just want more of
it cut because I love it I forgot that I
actually have a lot of edgy production
work so great what was this one this one
was true are you getting all of this so
this one was no no studio map is in his
kid oh this is uh this is Beckman Queens
later is airing so this is a lot of the
what cutters this is cut number check
exposure sheet cut 208 first hand yeah I
mean it's got a lot of cool stuff like
back whenever so this is like the
director's direction for Queens ladies
like boom Sun but handstand on days the
production though it's just it's super
regimented it's super budgeting and she
has to be efficient to produce otherwise
you're defeating the purpose because
you're trying to turn a profit you're
not trying to break even so horribly I'm
more of the oppai though more than the
that ass you know career soul do you
have anything you want to show us any of
your work no come on
[Music]
so ten of sankarea cut number 258 this
was back whenever even this the the made
uniforms that was just old but stuff
like South Korea and everything you
could even have a subset of it but I
think more romance but
fanservice is just prevalent everywhere
it's just that she's kind of just
more pronounced the zombie go yeah the
end of me I didn't read the manga I want
to really bad yeah because I agree with
you
fanservice is such an aspect of anime
that now if I don't see a lot of
fanservice I miss it
you know I'm like oh so I was looking
for a little bunny outfit you know yeah
so I've got like some you know I have a
lot of the production art and well not
production visit actual drawings and
Ganga it so it's called which is what
kids called Sakura nowadays I hate that
word but so like Queen's Blade is super
sexualized and like the way that they
produced this was like yeah okay so
there's super time effective because
this is an exposure sheet it's just a
way of just tracking animation and stuff
super weird but basically you have like
one that's why it's so still frightened
like I was like this it would be kind of
weird for it to be to animate something
that this is crazy detailed all the time
because it's just more budget it's
faster just put something out there
right and edgy and always feels like
that I think it's another big thing I
didn't get something just with ecchi
anime now it used to be but now it's
kind of bled into everything else I
think that a lot of anime try to be as
cheap as possible as far as production
that's why they outsource so much to
South Korea that's why they need to try
to export as much as they can to like
Hong Kong or Bangkok because it's
inexpensive and I heard that it almost
feels like of course it's not saying
that that's was case at all I'd say Walt
Disney he might have done something with
that back in the day but without FGM or
fanservice I think it's really hard to
say that like be a part of anime there's
a lot of enemy that I wish I could show
people but I know it's just too
difficult to kind of get past some of
the weird things about it even stuff
that I think is like perfect like it
would be perfect to show people for
instance my case is always I really want
to show
I mean Yuki wolf children to to certain
people but I know the one scene
with with like the wolf in her makes it
so hard to show because it's like hey I
don't come but condone bestiality it's
not all like this so let's get past it
and there's a really hard felt but
sometimes it's just you know that that
one factor about something is so hard
for people who have passed and I think
that people get passed in are super into
the phantom like if you walk away from
and they did a fan service that person
was probably gonna hate anime anyway at
that point one thing I wanted to mention
was it's hard to if someone wants to get
into anime it's really hard to introduce
an anime that's gonna have edgy
everywhere because it is unprecedented
and it is really weird at first glance
solid a full metal alchemist brotherhood
or my hero academia well even my hero
academia has slight fanservice where do
you go from there that's the problem is
that you don't have everything that goes
to that caliber that goes to that
extreme it's definitely the minority
because I've had friends where you you
give them stuff like code gifts or full
metal alchemist or darker than black but
the problem is is that eventually that
cream of the crop is gonna run out and
then I'll be left with anime and we all
know anime does certain things like the
let me wash your back right we've all
heard that a hundreds of times right
yeah it's such a commonplace thing that
we accept it as commonplace but to a new
viewer if they can't get past that it's
gonna be very difficult for them to get
past the majority of anime because Jason
I think you have to break them into
enemies first by showing them full of
Alchemist Brotherhood or Death Note
where the focus is not there at all and
then you can slowly you know move into
anime with more fanservice he's saying
yeah you can do that you can and all
these amazing series but they're so
limited eventually all they're going to
be left with is the broad spectrum of
what is anime really is you know what I
mean is once you show someone like five
good series that are not focused on and
also this is going on if you want to
show someone who isn't into anime
because he watched Shonen as a kid
because anyone that grew up was shown in
knows Naruto and bleach and one piece
all has those scenes right
we'll seize all of the Naruto sexy jutsu
in Episode one look forward Yuri watch
this execs what you're saying I think
that personally
yeah like weeping tears of Gurren Lagann
I love it I think everyone should see it
and also it's so over to talk in terms
of like it being studio trigger and
being crazy then a lot of people will be
like this isn't like my you know suits
TV show so I'm not going to watch this
but like those people are history man
because anime keeps growing even now if
you watch a game of Thrones they're full
of fanservice boobs everywhere it's just
the future so these people have to adapt
because animes becoming more and more
mainstream and yeah like I said
completely on ng it's hard for me to
like it unless it's really hilarious if
there's just an you know certain amount
of edgy but it's done in a way that
doesn't insult my intelligence and
there's actual plot to it like we're in
long I like Code Geass I'm all about
that no problem at all no I think the
problem with it is like with like
bringing something to anime while a lot
of people are fine recently anyway no
one wants to watch the older stuff yeah
I can't hear you on there together
you don't watch anything past like 2015
you were like no no 2008 that's his
limit mm April was it a little bit less
[Music]
anything below 2007 I don't tend to
watch because they're [ __ ]
yes e-coat guess who's 2006 yeah
yeah he was the first version in 2012
talking over each other now take it's
time to slowly wrap this up guys by the
way there will be a bit of an after
party voice chat in the discord if you
want to join that after this also we
will like if you like Grand Cafe support
the crew here and I will before we go I
will kind of throw it to all of you guys
to say who you are and what you do and I
don't know if you want to throw in your
favorite ecchi anime go ahead but Holden
we'll start with you sure my name is
Alton run channel Holden Casanova
it's amazing the context from talking to
me over Twitter YouTube anything my
recommendation to you I would actually
manga if you want to actually serious
I'd say something like I'm not su X
trash
it's a manga about water polo I like it
there is an anime to that it was a weird
day like horrible baby
I'm actually Serbian we're the best in
the world at water polo so I actually
really like water polo so that's
interesting
yeah it's a lot of fun it's a pretty
funny series you know there's guys
wearing Speedos trying not to get
erections cuz they're wearing Speedos
i think it's funny it's pretty stupid
it's a good time I think that if you
definitely a Shinichi I think that
mangas usually done it does it in a much
more interesting way and there's a lot
more of it just in general manga of
course you know one guys you know it's
not much of a risk for any person to put
out their ideas or concepts so if you
ever want to get something that's nice
always left among I said longer you
don't have to keep pressing the pause
button am i right guys
you had to press the next page button no
no you don't have to if you go in
certain sites you just scroll down bro
to scroll down all missed his joke how
did no one get where's your school so
lock up yeah yeah I'm so maka I mainly
focus on manga cuz manga is where it's
at that's where you can get your most
content really and you don't have to
worry about Oh does the animation look
crap but yeah I should be having some
videos uploaded tomorrow on my channel
yes obviously like it there's only one
video there at the moment check out
tomorrow hopefully they'll be more
content there for you know a link in the
description now gotta I do funny skits
and Anime News and soon I'm just going
to be moving to animations hell yeah
mark feeds your favorite itchy kill kill
all the way oh no I don't count that as
edgy I know think that you define as
good cannot be also defined as edgy but
killer kill his way to plot center to be
god that's good okay well now a god are
considered an edgy so she can choose it
as your favorite edgy no I'll say
monster
I know monster Musume that was good I
guess I can't assume the tutorial powers
yet but thank you now uh let's now go to
anime raka you got oh boy
it's me Mickey Mouse no I do them top
ten videos and I'm my favorite edgy his
highschool DxD just mute him I just want
to clarify this I'll stand behind the
statements of anime recon or anime
recons affiliate that was alright and
more worried with NOx which if you
haven't seen the challenge definitely be
sure to check it out link in the
description it was it was a fun time it
was a frustrating Knox I want it we
already spoke about most of my favorite
edgy anime like shokugeki no soma and
JoJo's Bizarre Adventure but what I what
I would like to mention since no one
said anything about it I think seven
deadly sins is one of my favorite edgy
anime or at least has many edgy points
did because it's focused more on the
Shonan and Cask and not focused on the
edgy again i would just say that's a
shown in with fanservice no not that
seven i was talking about the rape
invested idubbbz the video seven deadly
sins of rice gum oh I was thinking about
the one that's like basically Queen's
Blade melia deaths in the group enemy
content on my channel sarcastic in
analysis and that is all yeah
paradoxically NOx does really sarcastic
content and also like in-depth analyses
so people are very confused
as to which is which people don't know
what is going on it's not like I know
what's going on either so we're all the
same group here for example he analyzed
the potato chip seen in in definite way
before mother's basement and he just
your eyes it's like is it serious
is it sarcasm is it both if it's it's
really thank you dang it
well guys thank you everyone for joining
us for ANCA Fei Thank You Holden for
being here with us for the first days
later having everyone in the chat as
well thank you for participating there
was a lot of discussion went out I
couldn't you know mention chat too often
but you guys definitely contributed a
lot they saw some crazy [ __ ] as usual
some actual common sense sure that made
sense so yeah thank you everybody
next week we're back at 5 p.m. Eastern
Standard Time as always and until that
next time see us bass Cowboys no stop
stop because of drugs